hi james
all right we'll get started first
question brian smith
james how would you describe your
your focus maybe your your confidence
your intensity coming into this game
after the seven game series
against oklahoma city that was so tough
for your team
uh we had to turn the page and i think
we did a really good job with that
um you know yesterday just having one
day to prepare
guys were focused guys were locked in on
you know what what they love to do
and um and how can we just be it be you
know active and
how can we just affect that you know
affect that rhythm offensively
um defensively just making sure that you
know we're on the same page and we have
each other's backs and
um they came out with a lot of energy
but you know we just sustain it and
just continue to play our game i think
if we just continue to do that uh
you know we'll give ourselves a chance
greg bailey hey james maybe along those
lines what kind of mindset did you bring
in to be
so aggressive early at both ends of the
court and what kind of tone do you think
that set for you guys tonight
i'm talking about individually or as a
team well i mean maybe individually for
you with the way you scored and defended
particularly early to kind of get you
guys going
yeah i mean that's this is a really good
team the number one in our conference
and so
we had to get off to a really good start
and we did that we were just competing
competing
until we figured out you know what they
were doing and uh we just try to kept
keep attacking
they're they're a good team and when you
give them opportunities to
you know place long play into their
hands uh they have the advantage
so we wanted to keep our pace up uh
you know and defensively be active you
know make those guys work
um as hard as we you know we can and uh
make everything tough for them
jonathan way you guys have been
defending in the postseason and really
in the bubble the whole time does it
take a great deal of pressure off to
not have to go out and score 120 to win
yeah yeah because games aren't going to
be you know obviously we want to make
shots you know guys don't try to
try not to make shots but you know
obviously if shots aren't falling for us
we have something to fall back on that's
our defense and we've been showing that
you know
even in our last series in okc uh there
are a few games
we didn't shoot the ball well but our
defense one is basketball games and
uh that's that's a great sign for our
team
thank you mark berman
things i know it can be a long series
but can a game one like this
set the tone for a series i set the tone
but it's only one game
you know it's only one game we gotta you
know watch film and
you know the playoffs is about making
adjustments you know i'm sure we're
gonna we're gonna make adjustments
they're to make adjustments and
um you know we got to get ready for game
two
get that we got to be even better uh
game two because
uh you know the principles and the
schemes and all that stuff will ramp up
so guys got to be more even more engaged
tim mcmahon james what is uh
eric gordon's willingness to take a
challenge on lebron and and pj's
willingness to take the challenge on uh
on a.d
do for you guys defensively everything
everything and then we switch a lot too
so
it's not it's obviously those two guys
played extremely well defensively eric
got it going offensively
but it's our entire team you know we got
to take on a challenger whoever
in front of us has the ball uh to make
sure we're able to guard the ball
as best as we can and then the weak side
is is a you know we can't rely on our
weak side you know we got to be able to
make sure we protect the ball first and
then uh our weak side is just
extra you know they're they're our
backbone so uh
it starts off with eric and pj but then
whoever gets switched on you know those
two great players you gotta
you know be ready to guard the ball
first
dan wokey hey james um
people spend a lot of time kind of along
those lines talking about
how small supposedly you guys are but
you guys are all pretty strong um in a
series like this how does that strength
matter
um it seemed like tonight there are a
bunch of times when pj was able to body
yourself was able to body eric was able
to kind of go physically with them
um in just terms of just brute strength
i don't know why people keep saying
we're small like i don't care if you're
seven feet if you don't have
if you don't have heart it doesn't
matter you know if you don't have a dog
in you it doesn't matter so you know we
got guys that are able to switch and
play different positions and and guard
you know each uh different guys on the
court
um so it doesn't matter how tall you are
if you have the heart and your
competitor
you know you can be out there on the
court
kim davis
hey james um pj said when we talked to
him yesterday that some of the keys were
going to be
uh matchups how you guys wish and how
you communicated
all those things that that play into the
kind of defense you guys played
tonight yeah that's going to be our
defense every game
making sure we communicate on our
switches uh that helps us
be in positions to be able to rebound
the basketball it's extremely important
that we communicate because
you know we're smaller as far as height
wise so we have to be
positioned well to rebound to basketball
as a team so
that's the first part of our defense is
communicating uh switching
and then knowing where our help is and
uh making sure we're positioned to
rebound the basketball when a shot goes
up so
uh we've been doing that you know even
last series uh and then tonight so we
just gotta carry that and we gotta be
even better
because they're gonna be more aggressive
in game two
mark medina
the key is uh just going out there and
competing and having a heart you know
i think uh they saw something as far as
giving us opportunities and spacing
um and then we brought a shooter in you
know so the room was more
you know open for guys you know to drive
um
but you know all that being with all
that being said i think
we're we're great at is our defense and
um offensively we can score with the
best of them
but defensively i think we found it and
if we can continue to just
you know guard and lock in our defensive
uh coverages
then uh the plan worked but um
i got more than you know more confidence
in our guys man we just we work our
butts off and
we compete and that's all you can ask
for from team
ryan mahoney
uh james when you said a couple minutes
ago that uh yeah you gotta have dog in
you
uh what is that exactly how do you uh
what do you
define that as you wanna be a competitor
you gotta be a competitor you gotta take
on a challenge everything isn't going to
be
great every single night every
possession you know some sometimes
you're going to struggle sometimes
you're going to be playing well but
i think you got that competitive spirit
and you got you have the will
to want to get get things done um and
that that makes up for
anybody that's tall that's seven feet
we'll take two more adam spolan
james what did you see from the group
that uh was on the floor when you went
to the bench in the third when you guys
uh expanded the lead from three to
fifteen
uh we got stops we got stopped some guys
you know
we're in attack on i think eric got it
going um
which helped us a lot you know but our
defense you know they
give the number one team in the west
under 100 points
um you know that's that's a good defense
you know so but we got to be even better
uh like i said game two is going to be a
lot of adjustments
and we got to be ready for it and we got
to prepare for it and
you know try to try our best to keep
going like that each possession
and last one brian smith
james how how confident is this team
right now coming coming off the the
tough okc
series having this game one win and and
knowing where you believe you stand
in the nba our confidence never changes
win or lose you know you just sometimes
you lose and you don't play well
um but our confidence never changes you
know we have confidence in each other
and
we keep that encouragement up throughout
the course of games you know encouraging
guys to shoot
encouraging guys to be aggressive
defensive defensively having each
other's backs
i think once you that you know is is uh
you know it's contagious you know once
we feed that energy off to each
individual guy
that gives you the confidence to go out
there and just play you and be free
and uh i think that's in each each and
every one of our guys we have that
and um you know this playoffs has been
showing so
tonight's only one game uh watch film
tomorrow be ready for game two
thank you james
russell's next if you have a question
please use the raised hand feature
over there for me i don't work out for
none
hi russell hey trace how you doing
i'm great yes sir
we'll get started first question
kim davis
hey um russ can you talk about the
defensive effort you guys played
had tonight keeping the best team in the
west under 100 points
and um other people seem to recognize
that this team has been playing so well
defensively like watching it on tv they
said
this has been the best defensive team in
the bubble in the postseason so can you
talk about your defense
um just doing a good job covering for
each other you know we
we're small out there so we got to be
scrappy we got to play hard
because if we don't our chances of
winning will come down and
our guys in locker room know that and um
everybody stepped up on all levels
defending you know rebounding using our
quickness
it was beneficial tonight
jonathan fagan russ the way you put that
meeting to be scrappy and james said you
have to have heart and
be a dog does that fit the personality
on this team
got to be you know when you're competing
for a championship you gotta leave it on
the floor
because game one game seven doesn't
matter
every game every possession is important
and that's how we got to play it
greg bailey
hey russ what were a couple of keys
there i think you guys put together what
was a 14-0
run i think your big three was a part of
that down the stretch what'd you just do
so well to pull away
uh we just defended um we took our time
and
defended at a high level and got some of
the shots that we wanted um we didn't
settle
and that's big for us when we were able
to you know attack and make plays
for other people and another good
stretch for us
tim mcmahon russ early in the fourth
quarter there
uh after a whistle danny green's trying
to get a practice shot off and you're
not even letting them
uh get that shot off what message
are you trying to sit in there what tone
you trying to set there
i'm telling that we here you know we
know
you're not going no no extra shots you
can shoot those shots tomorrow
before the game but we not
at least me personally you know and my
guys know that i'm not
i don't i don't want to give no
advantage no nothing
to let him know that we're here and
every time he shoots the ball we're
going to be right there
mark medina
um just staying with it um you know
there's going to be games where it looks
like
we can kind of away away from it
but i think collectively we know how we
play we understand our advantage and um
it's just kind of up to us to make sure
that we implement that when we step on
the floor
royce young
hey russ um this might be kind of a
weird question for you but i don't know
when i'll have a chance to ask you
um you know you've uh you've always been
really great
at jump balls and i've seen you
personally win jump balls against
much bigger people than you and i'm just
curious with
the way you guys play um why don't you
ever want to do the opening jump ball
you know i thought about it one time but
um
especially against tim the makers do a
good job but
when they had to jump ball they like to
do the little live play that i'm aware
of so i'll stay i like to stay back but
i just gotten so used to just sitting
back and getting ready for the first
position on defense
gotcha thanks russ no problem
david chinolato uh
hey russ you guys have been playing
elite defense in the bubble
you you haven't you haven't played at
this level in the first part of the
season
uh when do you think you guys changed
mentality on defense
uh we never changed and there's times
for the season where you struggle
um you know and i think every team goes
through it
and for us to be able to win a
championship we got to defend
we know that and that's it
and last one christo saltos
hello russ congratulations uh what it
means this win
and especially the one the way that you
won tonight it was a kind of a statement
from you about the next games and how
about
how you feel after how's your shape
after the injury
um i think you know it's a serious
um and obviously when being ahead is is
great but
we we haven't done nothing yet and as we
know
it's a series and you got to be able to
come up with the same intensity
and find a way to be consistent moving
to the next game
and as far as injury-wise now i'm
getting better you know
just finding my legs still and
continue to push through and trying to
help my team while i'm on the floor
thank you russell yep